benedict hatch on the right and his crew
are approaching another shipwreck
an old sunken submarine
they scan it using sonar equipment
there are probably about 5 000 wrecks in
polish waters
and we only know about 20 of the area of
sea floor that belongs to poland
with 80 of the seafloor unexplored
thousands of shipwrecks could be
releasing toxic chemicals
most of the wrecks are from world war ii
one of the most toxic wrecks was
discovered by benedict hatch
the stuttgart was once an upscale
passenger steamship before being
repurposed into a hospital ship in
hitler's navy
it sank in 1943 after being struck by
american forces
this sonar image shows the stuttgart
shipwreck and how it's turned into a
field of debris on the seafloor
but the really frightening thing is what
benedict hatch found surrounding the
ship
the researchers took samples of the
seafloor and brought them back up to the
surface
this dredging equipment is dripping with
a black sticky substance
oil from the stuttgart shipwreck
the oil is heavier than water preventing
it from floating to the surface
instead it's been seeping into the
ground for decades
wow
we're on the verge of an ecological
disaster
the team found over 400 000 square
meters of the seafloor to be
contaminated with fuel that's the
equivalent of about 40 soccer [ __ ]
the eighty-year-old fuel shows up on the
surface as a trail of oil
it's just a question of time before it
washes up on beaches
i've spent many years of my life there
i've often gone for walks on the beach
with my wife too
and when our granddaughter comes to
visit we like to take her to the beach
it would be an irreplaceable loss if we
couldn't go there anymore
the shipwreck explorer and his crew
can't recover the toxic war debris
it's not clear who's even responsible
for such a task which would cost
millions most of the ships sunk in
polish territorial waters were german
other countries along the baltic sea
like finland sweden and germany have
retrieved individual wrecks from their
own territorial waters
but poland hasn't
benedict hatch says there's a lack of
know-how and so far no one has taken the
initiative
sometimes
people say you don't have to fry the
fish from here in oil anymore
because they already contain oil
most people only see water when they
look out to sea
benedict hatch has made it his mission
to show what lies beneath the surface
you